[Music]
peru
per capita no country has buried more
covet 19 victims
the highly transmissible new lambda
variant has intensified the tragedy
combined with challenging local factors
now after months of lockdown the country
is opening up again
but lambda hasn't gone away and experts
are raising the alarm about a
potentially
devastating third wave
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us
alpha data gamma delta and now
the who so far classes it as a variant
of
interest for peruvians it's much worse
peru's doctors have had enough after
putting their lives on the line
they want their government to protect
them with a booster shot of the biontec
fisa vaccine
we've been given cyanofarm which is just
52 percent effective
we are at the cusp of the third wave
health workers are in icus with a high
viral load
the health ministry insists there is no
clinical proof a third shot will help
it's a sensitive subject in the country
with the highest death toll per capita
in the world that's down in large part
to the little known lambda variant
which accounts for more than 97 of cases
for the moment there is no evidence to
suggest a more aggressive behavior for
the lambda variant
it is possible that the transmission
capability is increased
peru's plight has not been helped by
months of political unrest
which has seen mass protests
[Applause]
in recent weeks authorities have upped
the ante in the race to inoculate the
country
vaccine centers were opened up through
the night as part of a campaign to
encourage take-up
spring basis 36 uninterrupted hours of
vaccination
so that we don't have any excuse for not
going to get immunized
the vaccine is life the vaccine protects
us
[Music]
outside a morgue healthcare workers
gather again
this time to pay their respects to a
colleague who reportedly died from covet
19.
for more i'm joined by pablo tsukayama
he's a microbiologist and international
fellow
at the cayetano heredia university in
lima and he's been tracking the spread
of the lambda variant across peruvian
weather variant was first discovered so
good to have you with us
so please tell me what do we know by now
about this variant
how exactly does it differ from the
other ones that exist already
right um i guess the main concern here
is how how little we know about
it and there is it's not something
special about this variant but
where is coming from from from latin
america
so nowadays we have around 2.5 million
viral sequences that are available
online
however less than three percent of those
are from south america so our capacity
to investigate which variants are
circulating or are emerging in the
region
is quite limited so we
have been reporting on lambda since
april
as you mentioned is something that
originated in peru probably
in late 2020 and this coincides
with a rise in cases and deaths that
were seen
not only in peru but all over south
america
so the rise of lambda in peru in chile
and argentina and other places
also coincides with uh massive second
waves of the disease that have been
worse
than the first and all the religion is
just coming out of that
so we've had very long very sustained
high peaks of of
transmission and it is possible that
this lambda variant
along with the gamma variant from brazil
are the ones that are mostly responsible
for this new wave
of comic cases in south america right
but what you're saying also implies that
uh the lambda variant is
definitely then more contagious than the
other ones that have been around if if
there's a
correlation between the spikes and also
sadly the number of deaths
yes so very rapidly uh from the first
case that we detected in december
the lambda variant became the dominant
uh
variant in peru by march it was already
50
of all the cases in lima the capital
city and by
april it was already 80 percent of all
the cases
so this rapid increase from less than 1
in 100 to being 80
of all the cases in the country i
strongly suggests
that lambda is indeed a more
transmissible variant otherwise there's
no way to
to explain it and this has happened in
the presence of other
more transmissible variants like gamma
or alpha which are already circulating
in the region we need to do more
follow-up experiments to demonstrate its
higher transmissibility
but again early early evidence suggests
that it is indeed more transmissible and
he can put up a fight
with with gamma and alpha and now
and now we will see how it behaves
against delta now that it has entered
the region
and because you just mentioned delta i
mean the delta variant has already
caused havoc
in in india it is now pretty much the
dominant
variant throughout of europe uh and we
already
have reports about the lambda variant
reaching
other parts outside of latin america
including europe
do you expect bigger problems there i
mean how should we prepare
uh unfortunately there's no specific
measures that one can take about
specific variants and and much of the
vaccinated world and western europe and
the u.s are already taking
making strategies to cope with delta
which is mostly getting vaccinated but
yes indeed
lambda has been reported outside latin
america it has
likely been exported through travelers
going to north america
and to europe and we are already seeing
evidence of
sustained transmission locally in places
like the uk
spain france and especially germany uh
there's
there's a lot of sequences coming from
germany that indicate that it's already
present in
multiple regions and there's already
sustained transmission so
we'll have to see how it keeps evolving
and whether it can overcome delta in
these places although
it is already evident that delta is the
dominant form in europe so it will be
hard to
to toggle that yeah but given given that
the lambda variant is is very serious
one and really causing problems in latin
america and peru particularly
what do you make of the wh oh so far
only talking about a variant of
interest not yet one a variant of
concern does that
concern you
i mean it is certainly concerning for us
it is
what we believe has caused the most
trouble in peru in the last few months
the fact that it is only considered a
variant of interest
is mostly because we have little
evidence
about it because as a whole has not done
all the follow-up experiments that you
would expect to confirm all these
properties
so now that it's been designated as a
variant of interests
more labs that have access to better
tests and better infrastructure will
start conducting all these tests
and and experiments and new new studies
that are designed
to prove whether uh lambda is indeed
more transmissible
if it's more virulent or if it has some
immune scape properties so we'll see
about that but certainly it is a concern
in the region
and now most countries in the region are
coming down of the second peak of cases
but with low vaccination rates we are
expecting a third peak in the winter
and we will see whether it is delta or
lambda
or gamma the one that ends up dominating
and i guess we'll find out the
the hard way if things continue the way
it's been for 2021
really the situation in latin america
has been quite tragic
and uh we we expect some more waves to
scope it before the end of the year
until we reach massive vaccination rates
wow worrying outlook there but thank you
so much pablo tsukayamo
fellow at the university uh cayetano
heredia
in peru thank you so much for your time
thank you very much
now derek williams is also tackling one
of your questions about the trouble with
variance
here it is
will covert 19 variants just grow
stronger and stronger over time
this is a tough question to answer
because it assumes
that evolution is predictable which it
isn't
a mutation happens randomly
in virus genomes as they replicate
and the physical changes that those
genetic changes end up causing in the
virus
is what we mean when we talk about it
evolving
a tiny fraction of those mutations by
just by sheer
dumb luck they'll provide variants with
evolutionary advantages of some kind a
big advantage
as we've seen for instance with the the
alpha
and the delta variants of sars cov2
is if a variant becomes more
transmissible for some reason but
transmissibility can increase for a
range of reasons
and one is say that a variant is able to
get your cells
to make a lot more of it than your
average workaday
sars kobe 2 virus can another
would be if a variant were able to
remain
viable longer in the environment hence
increasing its chances of infecting
someone so
very different reasons same effect
see what i mean about predicting this
stuff so
when you say stronger and stronger which
i
assume means causing worse and worse
disease then you have to start by asking
whether doing so would provide a variant
with an evolutionary advantage of some
kind
and and it's hard to see how it would a
lot of virologists say
a more optimal combination of traits for
a virus
is to grow eventually more transmissible
but at the same time
less deadly because if a pathogen
doesn't kill
people they're going to be around to
spread it to others and they're more
likely to let down their guard
and infect each other with it so though
we can't predict with any certainty
what future sars kobe 2 variants will
look like
many experts expect them to spread more
easily
but cause less severe disease it could
well be that within 10 or 20 years
getting covet 19 won't be any worse for
the average person than
say catching a cold is today but
because evolution isn't predictable
that's just a hopeful guess
[Music]
good guess though that's all for now
thanks for watching